and welcome back to the many unanswered
questions about Russia's Wagner group
now that its Army of mercenaries has
apparently ended its revolt against the
Russian government how much support does
it really have inside of Russia and the
big question what's next for its leader
yegiveni Ferguson who promised to go
into Exile after building an
organization that he thought anyway
might be able to challenge the Kremlin
Charlie dagada has more now on this
Russian warlord homegrown there
Leningrad boy Charlie good morning
Good morning Tony he was a petty Thief
who eventually came to run a restaurant
chain earning him the nickname of Putin
chef and yet the past few days he led an
apparent coup attempt in the greatest
threat to President Putin's 24-year rule
yevgeni pregosian Rose to prominence on
the bloodiest battlefields of Ukraine
rallying his Wagner mercenary group to
territorial victories where the regular
Russian military fell in defeat most
notably in the fiercest fight of the war
so far Buck moot
but the 62 year old's Shady criminal
career began with a 12-year jail term
for robbery and assault he went on to
run a string of restaurants in Saint
Petersburg where he befriended Vladimir
Putin and got the nickname Putin's Chef
Jeff Hahn is a Russian expert at the
London School of economics in St
Petersburg in the 90s where there were
open bombings and assassinations you
were not a successful businessman unless
you were able to offer protection or Buy
protection and he seems to be someone
who was offering protection from running
crime rackets back then to troll Farms
now accused of meddling in the U.S
presidential elections pregosian the
FBI's Most Wanted since 2018.
is Wagner group of mercenaries has
established a reputation for brutality
accused of atrocities around the globe
deployed to Syria to fight alongside the
forces of President Bashar al-assad as
reported by cbs's Deborah patta
providing security for the president of
the Central African Republic in exchange
for lucrative gold mining contracts the
Department of Treasury will be
designated Wagner as a significant
transnational criminal organization
things turn sour in Ukraine between
pregosian and the Russian military Elite
in the late spring
calling out the Russian defense minister
and a top general of starving his forces
in ammunition and Equipment costing the
lives of thousands
now after squaring off against Putin
himself banished to Belarus what next
for yevgeny people keep saying that he's
marked for assassination there's a very
good chance I don't think it might come
from the Kremlin I think it might come
from the ministry of Defense because he
embarrassed them hugely but then again
he's been marked for assassination since
the 90s
so he's not the kind of character to go
into hiding but he's now a warlord
forced into early retirement another big
question is what becomes a the Wagner
group without its leader in regions like
Africa in the Middle East Gail
Charlie everybody always says Vladimir
Putin has a very long memory that he
never forgets don't you think that Rick
ocean is always going to have to sleep
with one eye open doesn't make sense
that he can go to Belarus and everything
is okay all forgiven there may have been
some guarantees about his security and
you know as as our guest has said this
guy has been living with a Target on his
head since the 90s so he's used to
living with assassination threats and
attempts over his head you have to
believe that some sort of deal was
brokered that would uh guarantee his
Security in Belarus but again it may not
be the Kremlin but the generals who come
after him because he's the one he's
they're the ones he's been bad-mouthing
more than anybody
yeah we shall see it was an
extraordinary weekend thank you very
much Charlie Daggett a reporting from
London